حتى الان عالقه في المعبر طبعا نادين هذه
الشاحنات هي بدايه القافله التي ستصل الى
هنا هناك ايضا 42 شاحنه تحمل مواد الطبيه
واغاثيه مقدمه من مجموعه من المنظمات التي
تعمل في شمال شرق البلاد بمعنى اننا نتحدث
عن حوالي 100 شاحنه من المفترض ان تدخل
الى هذا عبر هذا المعبر الى المناطق
المنكوبه لكن حتى الان لا توجد موافقه من
الطرف الاخر للسماح بعبورها
يبقى معنا من معبر جلود في منبج مراسل
العربيه جمعه جمعه مرحبا بك هل ما زالت
هذه الشاحنات متوقفه او عالقه او ممنوعه
من الدخول مرحبا بكم بالساده المشاهدين في
تركيا نعم انا الان في معبر
مصر بين منا كل الاغراض بحيث واقف وبين
مناطق المعارضه كما تظهر في الصوره هذا هو
الجدار الذي يفصل او بوابه المعبر التي
تفصل بين مناطق الاداره الذاتيه ومناطق
المعارضه في شمال غرب البلاد لا يزال
الوضع على حاله دون اي تغيير لم تدخل واي
واحده من الشاحنات التي ارسلتها الاداره
الذاتيه وعددها هنا في المعبر كما تلاحظ
30 شاحنه محمله
بالوقود اي مادتي البنزين والمازوت
المطلوبه بشكل سريع في المناطق المتضرره
ليشحها هناك ايضا هناك سبع شاحنات محمله
بالمواد
الاغاثيه موجوده مقدمه من الاهالي ولم
تدخل حتى الان
يتوقع ايضا ان تصل خلال يعني ساعات 42
شاحنه محملا بالمواد الطبيه واليغاثيه
مقدمه من منظمات المجتمع المدني والاهالي
الى هذه المنطقه وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
حوالي 100 شاحنه هنا في معبر ام ام الجلود
من المفترض ان تدخل الى مناطق المعارضه
ليس ببعيد من هنا نحن يعني على بعد حوالي
عشر دقائق من معبر التائهه وهو معبر ايضا
تتواجد فيه 100 شاحنه اخرى اضافه الى
شاحنات وسيارات اسعاف ارسلتها الاداره
الذاتيه ويفترض ان تصل الى مناطق النظام
في حلب لكن هناك تاسيس لهذه المساعدات
وعرقله لدخولها الى سوى الى مناطق النظام
او الى مناطق المعارضه بخصوص مناطق
المعارضه كان هناك لقاء منذ حوالي ساعه
بين الاداره واطراف وطرف في المعارضه
عندما عاد الى الداخل وفاوض من لا اعرف اي
جهه لكنه عاد الى الاداره الذاتيه وقال له
بانه لا يستطيع استلام هذه المساعدات
واعتقد انهم كانوا من الدفاع المدني اذا
يعني هذه نعم فشلت هذه المفاوضات يبدو ان
هناك اكثر من جهه تتحكم بقرار ادخال هذه
المساعده التي تتحكم بهذا القرار جمعه
ولماذا يعني ما الاسباب التي تمنع دخول
هذه المساعدات ان كان لديك اي معلومات
طبعا الخلافات السياسيه والعسكريه بين
الاداره الذاتيه والمعارضه لا تزال قائمه